Let me pick up next on our caller from the
seven area code seven seven two.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
Hi.
This me?
Yes, it is.
I'm.
Andrew, I'm from Jacksonville, Florida.
Andrew, what's going on?
I just wanted to get your your opinion about
Kellyanne Conway and her husband, George Conway,
and that dynamic is between them.
And I have a theory that she's the one that
wrote that New York Times op ed resistance
piece and that she is completely on board
with George Holloway's critiques of the president.
It's interesting you mentioned that.
So you're not the first person that has suggested
to me that it's Kellyanne Conway who wrote
that anonymous critique of the Trump administration.
For people who don't know, Kellyanne Conway
is an adviser to Donald Trump and very public
Trump defender.
Her husband, George Conway, is a Republican
who has been one of Trump's absolute biggest
critics of funding all sorts of anti Trump
ads.
And I mean, it's so so people are having a
hard time understanding how it is that they're
just living together at home.
Like how is it possible that these two people
could live together?
So one of the ideas is exactly what Andrew
is suggesting, which is, Kate, they actually
are on the same page when it comes to Trump.
And Kellyanne is just publicly remaining positive
about Trump.
But privately actually is on board with George
Conway.
I don't know the answer, but I've publicly
said before, I don't understand how the relationship
works because, you know, you've got James
Carville and Mary Matalin, Democratic and
Republican strategists who are married.
But they it seems as though they've figured
out a way where they're both they're not really
fighting each other in on any individual race.
Typically, Conway and Conway, Kellyanne and
George, I don't get how it works.
And your idea that maybe behind the scenes
they actually both hate Trump is certainly
a possibility.
Yeah, I agree.
Oh, can I just ask one more question?
Yeah.
What?
How do you take your coffee and like what
style of coffee do you.
I almost exclusively am drinking espresso
Brit based drinks right now.
I'm not really like a drip or filter coffee
guy.
So typically, you know, standard six sounds,
cappuccino is my go to certainly in the morning
and then, you know, I might make a half caf.
Now that it's quarantine, I'm making everything
at home so I can make a half caf ice lots.
Hey, now that it's warmer in the afternoon
or, you know, could be a macchiato, if I'm
feeling crazy, maybe I'll just have an espresso.
But I'm I'm mostly away from drip coffee and
filter coffee and on espresso.
OK.
Do you ever take a motto being from Argentina?
You know, I do it.
I'm not a big fan of it.
I'm just I've never it's never been a big
thing for me.
OK.
All right.
Well, thanks for taking my call.
Of course.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Great to hear from you.
Perfect phone call, I would say, ladies and
gentlemen.